sometimes movies make pretty bad first
impressions
years or even decades later however fans
and critics alike can change their tune
and once reviled releases are shown a
whole new level of appreciation
here are some of the movies that are
better than you actually remember
in space no one can hear you scream but
in the movie theater lots of people can
hear you getting mad
and boy did alien 3 make people mad
after ridley scott directed one of the
greatest sci-fi films
ever and james cameron followed it up
with one of the greatest action films
ever
david fincher's third installment in the
alien franchise was
well it wasn't the greatest anything
critics and audiences despised alien 3
though the film's box office wasn't that
bad earning 54 million
domestically and 158 million dollars
worldwide
arguably however alien 3 committed the
worst of all cinematic sins
it was disappointing following two of
the greatest genre films
ever is a tough gig to say the least
especially when your movie was supposed
to be the cinematic swan song
for one of the most beloved movie
characters of all time
it was a big ask and for some reason fox
handed the reins to first time
feature film director david fincher
alien 3 was an
inauspicious debut for the future
maestro who at 27 years old basically
told the head of fox to fire him
and has since disavowed the film itself
but alien 3 is actually pretty good
in addition to featuring one of the most
iconic shots of the entire series the
film has a great otherworldly vibe
focuses on a pretty cool prison planet
and sees sigourney weaver delivering
an incredible performance while it
suffered in 1992 for its close proximity
to alien and aliens
its reputation has only improved after
two decades of further disappointments
and duds in the franchise
and while alien 3 is far from fincher's
best it does demonstrate the early signs
of his remarkable creative vision
baywatch was once inexplicably the most
watched tv show in the world with a
staggering weekly audience of 1.1
billion people in 148 countries
this of course was despite the fact that
it really was kind of terrible
nonetheless with numbers like that it
was inevitable that hollywood would want
to make a movie based on the show
especially during this modern ip hungry
era
so muscle-bound movie stars dwayne the
rock johnson and zac efron donned the
board shorts and brought the slo-mo run
to a whole new generation
unfortunately the whole new generation
wasn't interested baywatch earned a
disastrous 17 percent tomato meter score
and not even the rock's 180 million
instagram followers could save it at the
box office
baywatch earned 58 million dollars
domestically and 177 million dollars
worldwide
a mediocre total saved only by its
modest 69 million dollar price tag
and while baywatch isn't good per se
it's still a cheeky send up of its genre
featuring a roster of super charismatic
stars
at the very least the movie more than
deserved its 2017 razzie for
so rotten you loved it superhero movie
fans had dreamed of seeing batman and
superman share the big screen
since well basically forever granted
nobody wanted to see them punching each
other in the rain while a flimsy mark
zuckerberg rip off waxed poetic about
grandma's peach tea
but hey you take what you can get
the red capes are coming
the red capes are coming
indeed it seemed that there was trouble
afoot when batman vs superman dawn of
justice moved its release date to avoid
captain america civil war
shocking fans who never thought they'd
see the day when the dark knight and the
men of steel
tucked tail to avoid captain america and
iron man
then when it was released dawn of
justice shocked critics and fans alike
in the worst possible way
the movie's grim tone and convoluted
plot totally missed the mark on what
made these characters so beloved and it
quickly lost favor with moviegoers
underperforming with 330 million dollars
domestically and 873 million dollars
worldwide
dawn of justice didn't win the 2017
razzie award but
ben affleck and henry cavill did take
home the trophy for worst
screen combo while the movie's
reputation is truly horrible
the shock of dawn of justice's
disappointment was by far the worst
thing about it and honestly
it's probably a little better than you
remember the movie's unabashed bonkers
storytelling stands out when compared to
say the mcu standard house style or
justice league
which was neutered into focus group
approved blandness
basically warner brothers gave snyder
263 million dollars to bring his
creative
insane vision to life resulting in one
of the most bizarre blockbusters of all
time
and it's never ever boring which is more
than you can say for some superhero
movies
who watches the watchmen not many people
apparently
after zack snyder spent a modest 60
million dollar sum on 300
and paid warner brothers back with
almost half a billion in worldwide box
office sales
the studio confidently cut him a 130
million dollar check to film their most
challenging property watchmen ever since
it changed the face of comics in 1986
many filmmakers had yearned to bring
alan moore and dave gibbons masterpiece
to the big screen
only to declare the dense tome
unfilmable
watchmen's journey through three decades
of development hell is like walking
through a graveyard of great directors
terry gilliam darren aronofsky and paul
greengrass all joined and then left the
project
given that critically acclaimed crew
it's surprising the one guy who finally
figured out watchmen was zack snyder
and despite what the history books say
he actually did a pretty good job
watchmen earned respectable rotten
tomatoes scores from critics and fans
but it bombed
at the box office earning 107 million
dollars domestically and 186 million
dollars worldwide
a steep 60 drop from the less
prestigious property 300
while costing twice as much nobody likes
a loser of course and watchman's poor
box office performance has earned it a
great deal of unfair criticism with some
fans even saying it hewed too closely to
the beloved source material
while watchmen is nowhere near as good
as the groundbreaking graphic novel
it's still a pretty solid adaptation
with some great superhero costumes
impressive fight scenes and pitch
perfect performances from the cast
thankfully in the wake of hbo's
critically acclaimed watchmen tv sequel
snyder's film has received a much
deserved reappraisal from
fans and critics alike making a movie
about pearl harbor inevitably demands
the talents of a filmmaker with grace
maturity
and skill so naturally the job went to
michael bay
bay's armageddon came in second in 1998
to steven spielberg's saving private
ryan so bay figured he'd mix the two
and throw in a touch of titanic for good
measure but pearl harbor wages war
against world war
ii recreating this pivotal historical
event not in the hyper-realistic
documentary style of spielberg but the
hyperkinetic video game style of
well michael bay you don't feel like
you're in pearl harbor so much as
in the middle of a video game about
pearl harbor in other words
it's a lot and while critics tried to
sync it with a 24
tomato meter score audiences saluted it
with a 198 million dollar domestic and
449 million dollar worldwide take
nevertheless its critical reputation
never really recovered
while pearl harbor isn't great however
it does deserve a re-watch
there have been great war films and bad
war films over the years but there have
been few that care so little about
asking the cliche big questions and care
so much about blowing stuff up real good
pearl harbor is like watching a man
child get to play with 140 million
dollars worth of fireworks on the 4th of
july
it's a nonsensical series of colorful
explosions and paper-thin patriotism
sure but man is it entertaining
first let's get one thing out of the way
godzilla is not a godzilla movie
g fans immediately condemned the
character as gino
or godzilla in name only and toho
studios even had the real godzilla mop
the floor with zilla in 46 seconds flat
in godzilla final wars
history has labelled godzilla a flop
largely due to the film not living up to
its insane hype
however the movie had the biggest
opening weekend of 1998 and that was
despite opening on a wednesday
and critics absolutely nuking it into
oblivion
direct hit but the target is still
moving sir
well circle around and fire again but it
wasn't beauty that killed the beast
it was word of mouth as godzilla's short
legs only managed a 136 million dollars
domestic and 379 million dollars
worldwide gross
moviegoers chief complaint it wasn't
godzilla
godzilla doesn't hide behind buildings
he knocks them down
godzilla doesn't run from the military
he blows them up
godzilla doesn't lay eggs he well
nobody's really sure but he definitely
doesn't lay eggs
but while godzilla isn't godzilla it's
still a perfectly acceptable summer
popcorn movie about a giant nuclear sea
iguana who just wants to lay his
or her eggs in peace just call it
something else and
enjoy it for what it is waterworld is
pretty much
synonymous with the term box office bomb
the bad buzz from waterworld's trouble
plagued shoot combined with poor
critical reviews killed whatever chances
it had of scoring big with audiences
in the end the movie underwhelmed with
88 million domestic and 264 million
dollars worldwide which isn't bad for an
original sci-fi but thanks to its absurd
175 million dollar price tag the movie
needed to be rescued from drowning by
its home video and cable sales
a high concept apocalyptic sci-fi
fantasy like water waterworld needed all
of the pieces in place to work and
unfortunately for the film none of them
did
the result is an ambitious creative
misfire with a critical and financial
reputation much worse than it deserves
years after its release critics and fans
are rediscovering the film and finally
acknowledging it wasn't really a box
office bomb
or a particularly bad movie thanks to
the nerve-wracking recession of the
polar ice caps it might even be scarily
prescient as well
arnold schwarzenegger reached his peak
in 1991 with his biggest hit and the
highest grossing movie of the year
terminator 2
judgment day going forward then there
was only one character big enough for
arnold to play
himself so schwarzenegger reunited with
his
predator director john mctiernan in the
pseudo-spoof last action hero
in which a lonely 11 year old arnold fan
is transported into the latest movie
starring the one man austrian army it
was a fairly clever story one that
allowed schwarzenegger to make fun of
his big screen persona while still
getting to be a total badass who killed
villains in creative ways while dropping
corny one-liners
don't give up your day job if you were
like the pre-teen boy in the film last
action hero was the perfect introduction
to schwarzenegger
chances are last action hero was the
first arnold movie a lot of millennials
moms and dads allowed them to see thanks
to its pg-13 rating
alas cranky old critics couldn't stand
it and it suffered for having the bad
timing of opening one week before
jurassic park
last action hero wasn't a hit with
critics or arnie's r-rated fans and it
even earned a razzy nomination for worst
pitcher but for the 11 year old and all
of us
it's still a pretty awesome movie mars
attacks is a movie not meant for this
world because it deserved far
far better warner brothers gave tim
burton an 80 million dollar budget and
an all-star cast to make a spoof of the
1950s sci-fi schlock cinema burton had
adored as a child
critics were underwhelmed however and
audiences were even less impressed as
mars attacks crash landed with 37
million dollars domestic
and 101 million dollars worldwide making
it probably burton's biggest bomb
so what happened well the christmas
season release date was a failed attempt
at counter programming and it also had
the misfortune of opening six months
after 1996's biggest hit
another little sci-fi flick called
independence day
just one year later another alien
invasion comedy men in black became the
biggest hit of the summer
and that one had the advantage of having
independence day star will smith on the
cast
however while those two movies took the
extraterrestrial subject matter somewhat
seriously mars attacks lampooned it
mercilessly
in the end mars attacks just got buried
between two much bigger more popular
alien movies
but to a certain viewer it's actually
kind of brilliant with its mad cap humor
and mischievous sense of fun besides
wherever you think mars attacks ranks in
sci-fi canon it at least deserves kudos
for being the only alien invasion film
clever enough to not kill the aliens
with nukes bombs or bacteria
but with slim whitman records you gotta
give it credit just for that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you